when leah thomas dives into the pool she
could be sealing her place in ncaa
history the standout swimmer from the
university of pennsylvania will compete
to become the first division one openly
transgender athlete to be crowned a
national champion the u-pin swim team
posted this picture of leah and two
teammates poolside here they are all
three of our ncaa superstars her stellar
season has smashed records but also
courted a wave of controversy with some
fellow athletes and parents concerned
that thomas has an unfair physical
advantage thomas spent three seasons
competing on the u-pin men's swim team
and spoke candidly in december about her
struggle during that time my mental
health was not very good there was a lot
of unease
about basically just feeling
trapped in my body
she has now completed 34 months of
hormone replacement therapy surpassing
the 12-month ncaa requirement to compete
on the women's team
i
can continue to do the sport i love as
my authentic self it's left her
teammates split some sending a letter of
public support writing in part that
thomas and all transgender college
athletes deserve to be able to
participate in safe and welcoming
athletic environments while others have
spoken out in opposition one anonymous
teammate tells the philadelphia enquirer
she's concerned about physical
advantages that don't she says give the
other women a fair shot it's very
difficult to focus when there's a lot of
hatred and vitriol around you skylar
baylor was the first openly transgender
d1 athlete on a men's team he flew to
atlanta this week to show his support
for leah but we have to put our heads
underwater and swim and leah has done an
incredible job of that
you know what's funny about skyler what
he went from female to man right so he
was born a female transitioned to a man
yeah
literally one nothing
yeah this dude was an
he was a decent swimmer when he wasn't
was a male right then then she
transitioned to be a woman
broke the record
which is again
more of the same that i've said so you
guys may not get the craziest energy for
me but peep the game
uh
oh my god it's so hard to swim when you
got hatred and vitriol well why are
people so upset you're not gonna address
that you're just gonna skip over that
cool
just notice
it's hard to swim when people hate you
why are they saying all this stuff is it
just out of nowhere is it born of
nothingness or maybe there's some
credence no okay all right
sweep it under the rug
let's not talk about it
but she shouldn't have to put her
blinders on so many of us before leah
have tried to say hey we exist to
hopefully make the world a little bit
more ready right for the next trans
athlete
what was that
what's that someone said something about
uh
unfair huh huh what's that
so
i mean this person was training with the
men's team transition immediately broke
the women's record what do you think
she's do you think she's just more
talented than every other woman there in
the history of that you pen she just
happens to be the one person who
transitions
is the most talented woman
but you know what though i'm not even
mad because i don't even think women
work hard y'all some lazy bums who are
just waiting to start cooking and
cleaning for us
you mistake if you guys took more time
in your training she would have not
broken that record no but kim kardashian
said it the best women need to work more
you don't work you don't work enough so
for the girl that was 16 17 that was 17
and instead of 16 and got bumped yeah
work harder what do you want me to say
every problem it was a trans problem no
[ __ ] you just don't work hard enough
you just work harder that's why they're
breaking these records
that's what happens when you see a true
athlete who puts an effort in time well
guess what
they break the records of course we talk
about oh it's trans trans no you're a
piece of [ __ ] and you're transphobe and
you could suck some dick
sorry the last one
the last one's probably unnecessary you
ate [ __ ] for that one i didn't even
think about making i know but i was like
mommy listen hold up question when a
when a trans person tells you to suck
their dick okay all right yeah no we're
not doing that no no we're not doing
that
but a woman can say this you know i mean
if a woman tells me sucker dick i'm like
hey man you got a big [ __ ]
all right
how do we see the rest of these
championships playing out for her
hoda there is so much to watch so she is
going to first hit the pool this morning
at 10 o'clock that's the 500 yard
freestyle the prelims all right i'm
going to skip ahead for you guys she won
everything obviously okay easy peasy
lemon squeezy slapped up the competition
won by solid margin okay
world
beat the record okay for for women's
swimming
and
it was fascinating because when she went
up to go to the podium she was in first
then there was a girl in second
and the thing is like they all went up
in order so when the girl went up in
second they screamed and cheered when
she went up there was like booze
[Music]
[Applause]
uh
[Music]
so the crowd wasn't behind her because
they feel like this shit's [ __ ] her
team
i think out of like 32 people there's
about six people who support her the
rest of them are against what she's
doing or do not want to voice any
support for her because they don't
believe in it so even the people who are
supposed to be supporting her are not
with it
and
people are like well listen we want to
be inclusive all this stuff but you
don't recognize in your attempt to
include her you end up excluding other
people and i want to play video guys
that i saw that i thought i was really
telling your virginity tech swimmer what
did you think about leah thomas
competing today as a swimmer in this
competition what are you feeling what
are other athletes feeling it's a common
conception that we are all very
disappointed and frustrated with someone
who is
has capabilities more than us women have
to be able to compete at this level and
take opportunities away from other women
like i have a teammate who did not make
finals today because she was just bumped
out of finals and it's heartbreaking to
see someone who
went through puberty as a male and has
the body of a male
be able to
absolutely blow away the competition and
you go into with a mindset that you are
you don't have a chance
if that makes sense like it's hard to
compete against someone with
the aerobic capacity the muscle
development the body of a man it's hard
it's hard to think about it like that
and
staying positive i bet for other
swimmers who are in that
heat is probably
overwhelming i'm not sure i can't speak
for them but it's disappointing to see
and frustrating definitely and you said
that one of your teammates was crying
today because she didn't make the finals
you said that she was 17th yes and there
were 16 spots yes so leah thomas took
one of those spots talk to us about what
your teammate was going through and that
experience she was very emotional and
it's hard to see since her last ncaas
and
she really loves that race and it was
just heartbreaking to see that she put
all her effort into it today and when
the best time that she went in a morning
session before and still not make it
back
it's hard to see someone who works every
day every night
still not be able to
compete against someone like that
let's work harder
olympic weight lifters
historic night here uh with laurel
hubbard competing as the first openly
transgender in a uh
in a individual event i was wondering
you know what you felt about that and
what you felt that took place in in your
sport
no thank you
i think that no thank you was just like
not answering that question why do you
think they don't want to answer it
because it'd be very easy for them to be
supportive and say the woke thing the
reason why they don't say nothing is
because they know what they're going to
say is going to get backlash
that's the reason absolutely the reason
why i was quiet we're not taking this
question and then somebody would say
we're not talking about this yeah but we
know that we we that's the thing that we
know we know that women that are
competing are the biggest transform
they are i just don't understand i don't
understand the point of having
female sports if it's not going to be
for females
it's not about your gender expression
sports i always say is a matter of your
biology it's not about what you identify
as it's what your biology is you could
actually be a whole female
and not be able to compete because on
paper you produce too much testosterone
so we're going to exclude female
that don't go but we're going to include
i don't know maybe that's just weird and
the whole hormone therapy well if you do
this you meet the requirement no you
don't you don't you went through puberty
as a matter look at look at the
shoulders look at the body composition
look at everything it is very obvious
what gender that sorry when everyone
sucks that person whenever you whenever
you whenever you do to whenever you do
sterosteroids
okay athletes that are caught doing
storage there's a there's a lot of uh
doctors that say they should be banned
for life
because that changes the composition of
your
muscles
forever
the same thing as testosterone because
it increases testosterone that you have
in your body and you have more or those
little particles that makes your your
muscles bigger
and they should be bad for life because
even if they do not use steroids anymore
it changes that forever it's not the
same thing as a hormone therapy we are
talking about testosterone so even if
someone that has steroids
such as body lifters weight lifters and
stuff like that bodybuilders they do
that
even if they take hormone therapy
the testosterone goes over that a lot of
women that do uh a lot of women that do
steroids that do uh
bodybuilding and stuff like that they
require to have hormone shots and stuff
like that's hormone therapy because
they'd be looking like oh
it [ __ ] up your jaw it [ __ ] up your
voice it [ __ ] up your everything you
have acne and stuff like that and
sometimes they're there they have to
take hormone therapy but it still
doesn't change your muscles
it doesn't change the composition of
your muscle
now
the fact that you take that hormone
therapy yes hormonally speaking you test
your hormones you're going to fit the
description but your muscles are still
there
now
it's nothing that we haven't said before
facts so
but again that's not my fight
that's for them to fight
hey man that's the fight that's not me
i'm just watching from the sidelines i'm
not really losing much because this is
not even sports i really cared about i
just think it's blatantly unfair
and for the sake of identity politics
everyone's turning a blind eye which is
like
biology well [ __ ] the science let's talk
about inclusion
but i think it's blatantly obvious for
everyone to see i don't know how many
more world records we're gonna have to
see be shattered before they say let's
start dashing this [ __ ] away because
this they're not there's gonna have to
be just just whatever we're not gonna
see
female in the sports and it's just gonna
be
an all trains woman finals yeah it's
going to come it's oh it's going to come
very soon it's nothing i haven't said
before something that we haven't said
before you see the over excitement in my
in my face and the joy that is
non-existent in my voice that's what it
is it is what it is and it's gonna get
worse than that and it's fine i said it
before i'ma say it again you thought i
was trolling when i said that but i was
really serious you know what [ __ ] it
let's go all the way
that's what y'all want just go all the
way but they don't want that i think
women have made it abundantly clear they
don't want this
so but you see the women on the team
have said it the people on the stands
i've said it it's it's really the
government bodies but it's hard but it's
just but it's just like you're training
you're not saying anything so you need
to say something just like you training
you need to work harder or you're going
to get obliterated
that's what it is
if you don't say nothing you're going to
be obliterated and we're not going to
see female bodies in that those ports so
only the only sports i watch on youtube
are the women doing the long jumps and i
enjoy watching those okay but outside of
that the rest y'all can disappear i
don't give a [ __ ] work harder
and of course we're trolling but i'm not
you i watch the women's long jumps
yeah what about you guys are you guys
men of culture
you guys don't watch long jump
bam that's just fire fire whoever makes
those thumbnails know exactly what the
dudes are there
sure
whatever if they want to grab poles i'm
all for
hey man what do they want to hop over
what do you want to hop on i don't care
let's wrap this what do you mean let's
practice i mean i just never seen legs
move like that hey what do you guys
think no i'm just saying you don't you
don't agree
remember i was in the track team
hey man listen shout out shout outs to
them you know what i mean if you do
track
okay i just want to say that real quick
uh but as far as the rest of the women's
sports i don't give a [ __ ] as long as i
get to see my thumbnails when i jump on
youtube the rest of y'all can disappear
you don't like it work harder